with all the hype surrounding steam
machines it's easy to forget that you
don't need to buy a new system to check
out valves vision for the future of PC
gaming either users can check out a bisa
version of steam OS right now provided
they're rockin an Intel processor and an
Nvidia Intel or AMD graphics card
laptops that feature both discrete and
integrated graphics aren't currently
supported you'll also need at least a
500 gigabyte hard disk and four
gigabytes of RAM there are actually two
versions of steam OS to try out one with
less configuration required that
restores an image of CMOS to your PC and
another that runs through a standard OS
setup the restoration version requires
that you have a one terabyte hard drive
fitted if you're using a smaller drive
like a fast SSD for example you will
need to go through the standard set up
which is what we opted for once you've
downloaded the Installer from the steam
website you then need to extract the
contents of it to a USB stick bear in
mind that you'll need one at least two
gigabytes in size now simply plug it
into your PC and then boot from the USB
Drive by opening the boot selection
screen as startup you should be
presented with a list of boot options
select the UEFI entry for USB Drive and
the steamos installer will boot up
select automated install and the
installer will wipe the contents of your
hard drive partition it and install
steamos the process takes around 30
minutes or so so I don't know
go alphabetize your spice rack or
something during installation you may
run into an issue with your display
going to sleep and not waking up again
if you're plugged in via HDMI so if
possible go in via DVI if all goes well
you should be presented with a login
screen again if you're plugged in via
HDMI you may encounter an issue with the
screen resolution being incorrect upon
boot making it look like this the
solution other than to plug in via DVI
is hit the icon at the top right of the
screen and click the top option this
makes the text bigger allowing you to
select the gnome session from the login
window and log in with a username and
password steam
if when you reach the Linux desktop your
screen resolution is still incorrect you
need to go into the settings and
configure your display
okay next step you need to get steam OS
installed open up a terminal from the
applications window type in steam and
press ENTER once steam is installed
close the open windows and log out of
the system log into the gnome session
again this time using the username
desktop and the password desktop open up
another terminal window and type in the
following text terminal will prompt you
for a password which is also desktop the
system will automatically reboot and
create a recovery partition once that's
done the system will reboot again and
you'll finally be presented with the
Steam login screen unfortunately we
encountered yet another issue when we
connected via HDMI that caused an
incorrect resolution to be displayed in
steams big picture mode to fix this
first you need to enable access to the
desktop on the desktop open up another
terminal window then enter the following
text this will load up a text file where
you to find the line that says preload
before the preload line create a new
line and enter the following text
replacing the numbers with your
preferred resolution hit ctrl X on your
keyboard then why to save the file and
after a restart you should be presented
with the correct resolution and steams
big picture mode in all its wonderful
glory while that might seem like a lot
of effort to go - in order to get things
working in the grand scheme of Linux
steam OS fares pretty well everything
aside from the correct screen resolution
work straight away and clean things like
audio and the Ethernet port components
that traditionally require a bit of
terminal fiddling to get working even
swapping out an Nvidia card for an AMD
one didn't throw up any issues now you
can finally start playing some games
unfortunately the Linux selection isn't
the biggest right now but there are
quite a few indie games as well as valve
titles like dota 2 and left 4 dead 2
performance is good with comparable or
better frame rates in steam OS than in
Windows provided you're using an Nvidia
card
we found the current AMD drivers were
pretty flaky and gave us some pretty bad
frame rates but no doubt that'll be
improved in time and hey steamos is free
so you can give it a go without breaking
the bank and who knows if enough people
install it or buy a steam box there may
even be more than a handful of games to
play on it too
[Music]